una silla vacía era aquí en donde se
supone se debía vacunar el primer
ministro de tailandia una transmisión
que iba a ser en vivo y se canceló
después de que bangkok decidiera
retrasar la distribución de la vacuna de
astrazéneca fue luís y acabamos de
aplazar la vacunación de nuestro primer
ministro porque recibimos información de
agencias de noticias diciendo que en
europa algunos países suspendieron las
inoculaciones de gentex en tailandia se
une hacía varias naciones europeas que
congelaron las inyecciones de
astrazéneca ha sido un efecto dominó ha
causado por reportes aislados de
pacientes que han desarrollado coágulos
de sangre sin embargo la agencia europea
del medicamento manifiesta que no hay
indicios que apunten a que sea una
consecuencia de esas condiciones dice
este organismo que son más los
beneficios que los riesgos una posición
que comparten los países europeos que
continúan con la administración de esas
inyecciones tales como francia
sant millón europeo donde cinco millones
de europeos sólo 30 personas han sufrido
de coágulos de sangre a pesar de esos
mensajes estas suspensiones son otro
golpe para astrazéneca
algunas naciones de la unión europea
cuestionaron su eficacia sobre los
mayores de 65 años y su producción ha
sido incompleta solo entregando la mitad
de las cantidades acordadas en el primer
trimestre mientras tanto brasil que vive
sus peores días de la pandemia dio su
aprobación definitiva para esta vacuna
que igualmente ya se está aplicando
otras naciones como ecuador ya habían
dado luz verde al uso de este antídoto
otros territorios como bolivia colombia
o paraguay tienen acuerdos para comprar
dosis de esta vacuna que en europa ya
acumula dosis sin usar